[موسيقى]
من نافذه صغيره تصرخ هذه الطفله مستنجده
بامها بعد ان وجدت نفسها حبيسه بيتها مع
اخيها فالجنود داهموا البيت بشكل مفاجئ
واغلقوا ابوابه بالحديد والنار دون تنبيه
او سابق انذار بينما كانت الام خارج
المنزل الضابط الجيش
الاحتلاويه نازله من البيت ما حكى لها كان
هو الضابط وهو وكميه جنود هو وكميه جنود
نازلين يعني موجودين هون بس ما حكوا لانه
بده يسكروا الدار ولا بدهم يلحموا ولا
بدهم يسووا شيء في ولاد صغار عندك في
البيت عندك بنت عمرها سنتين ونص عندك ولد
عمره 12 سنه موجود هلا في البيت بامكانك
انك تشوف بمعنى مبينين على الشبابيك الدار
انا خايف عليهم
ليه كيف الحمووه واحنا
مش شايفين
[موسيقى]
بعد دقائق عادت الام والى المنزل لتجد
ابوابه مقفله بشكل كامل وطفليها يصرخان من
النافذه فاستدعت الجيران وبعض الناشطين
الذين هبوا لتقديم المساعده وخاضوا جدالا
طويلا مع الجنود لاقناعهم بضروره فتح
ابواب المنزل وتحرير الطفلين
تقطن عائله البايض شارع الشهداء وسط مدينه
الخليل وهو من الشوارع المقفله منذ سنوات
طوال ويعيش الاهالي فيه شبه سجن دائم
وتزداد قسوه السجن مع المناسبات والاعياد
التي يخرج فيها المستوطنون للشوارع حيث
قام الجنود باحكام اغلاق بعض البيوت
والمحلات التجاريه بذريعه توفير الامن عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه